Our Environment – Tō Tātou Taiao
The Waimakariri District is home to a beautiful and diverse natural environment
that stretches from the mountains to the sea.
We have protected forested areas, wetlands,
tussock and grasslands.
We have many waterways in which we are working
with Ngai Tuahuriri and Environment Canterbury
to improve the quality of the water.
We also have areas, especially in the east,
that are susceptible to natural hazards
such as flooding.
Our District - Our Future, Waimakariri 2048
aims to:
So what do you think?
Let us know your thoughts and find out more
about the District Development Strategy at
waimakariri.govt.nz